COOL.
I'M SO EXCITED. WHERE WE HAVE
KENDRICK PERKINS ON THE SHOW.
TODAY IS A LOT TO GET INTO
WITH KENDRICK PERKINS.
I WANT TO START WITH THE
FOOTBALL STUFF THOUGH.
KENDRICK HAS TJ WAS TALKING
ABOUT
I WAS GETTING EMOTIONAL SCENE,
THE GUYS FROM HIS CHILDHOOD,
GET INDUCTED,
YOU'VE HAD SOME OF YOUR
TEAMMATES NOW INDUCTED INTO
THE NAISMITH BASKETBALL HALL
OF FAME AS A FOOTBALL GUY.
A TEXAS GUY. WHAT'S IT LIKE
FOR YOU TO WATCH
THESE?
IS AND THESE MEN WHO
YOU ADMIRED FOR YEARS,
GET ENSHRINED, INTO THEIR
RESPECTIVE HALL OF FAME'S.
WELL, I MEAN, YOU GOTTA
UNDERSTAND THIS IS
WHEN YOU
ANSWER THE HALL OF FAME,
THAT'S THE THE
LEAD OF THE LEAK AND,
YOU KNOW, MAKING IT IN A
PROFESSIONAL SPORT IS ONE
THING,
BUT BEING
AN ALL-TIME GREAT IN LABELED
AS
ALL-TIME GREAT AND ACTUALLY
MASTERING THE
CRAFT. AND,
AND OVERACHIEVING TO THE MAX
WHERE YOU GET A GET INDUCTED
INTO
THAT'S ON ANOTHER LEVEL
AND YOU HAPPEN TO SEE
ANYBODY,
ANYBODY WAS IT, IT WAS
A YOUR PONY THAT YOU
PLAYED AGAINST WHAT, THERE WAS
A GUY YOU
WATCHING ANOTHER SPORT WHEN
YOU GO UP THERE, YOU WATCH
THOSE GUYS AND YOU WATCH
THOSE GUYS
SHED THOSE TEARS. A LOT OF
THOSE TEARS
ARE NOT BECAUSE YOU KNOW,
IT'S 20% OF THAT IS
HAPPINESS, RIGHT? BUT THEN YOU
HAVE 80% OF THAT.
THEY THOUGHT TO THINK BACK AND
REFLECT BACK ON A LIFE
LIFE
IN THE SACRIFICE AND THAT THEY
HAD TO DO IT.
SAYING THAT THEY HAD TO DO TO
GET TO THAT POINT
AND SO WHEN YOU WATCH IT, IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL THING TO SEE
YOU AT ANY LEVEL
KENDRICK PERKINS JOINS THE
SHOW
ESPN'S HOOP STREAMS
OF COURSE IS BIG PERK AND
AND KENDRICK YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE, YOU KNOW,
THE
THE EMOTION THAT THESE MEN
HAVE WHEN THEY'RE INDUCTED
INTO THE HALL OF FAME.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE NEW
TREND THAT'S HAPPENING AROUND
THE OLYMPICS WHEN OLYMPIC
ATHLETES WIN GOLD
MEDALS, THEY JUST CALL YOU OUT
AND THEY JUST SHOUT YOU OUT
AND THEY CURSE YOU OUT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK? THIS IS
GOING TO CATCH ON IS GOING TO
BE A TREND. WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IN FUTURE OLYMPICS,
YOU KNOW WHAT? LOOK WAIT WAIT.
WHEN YOU HAD DOUBT IN YOUR OWN
HEAD AND AND
AND LOOK LOOK
SARGE. LOOK, I APOLOGIZE TO
THE WORLD
IF I JUST HAD
EVOLVED BECAUSE I'M SPOILED,
RIGHT? BECAUSE I'M SPOILED
BECAUSE
THE DREAM TEAMS OF THE
PAST AND THE
KOBE BRYANT OLYMPIC
TEAMS
AND CARMELO, ANTHONY OLYMPIC
TEAMS, ONE AND GREAT
IF HION. EXCUSE ME,
HAVING HIGH EXPECTATIONS
FOR OUR COUNTRY, RIGHT?
IT'S ONE THING TO GO WIN IT
BUT HERE'S THE THING, RIGHT?
THAT JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU
THAT. I GOT A LOT OF REAL
ESTATE IN A LOT OF THESE
GUYS HERE
AND THERE JUST WATCHING ME AND
I GOT
5,000 SQUARE FOOT AND THEY
10,000 SQUARE FOOT
PALLIATIVE WITH A BEDROOM
IN EVERYTHING. NOT A FACT THEY
SERVED ME BREAKFAST IN BED
RIGHT NOW. SO IT'S A GOOD
THING. I'M HAPPY THAT THE GUYS
ACTUALLY WANT
BECAUSE I WAS ROOTING FOR
HIM.
BUT, YOU KNOW, HERE'S THE
THING.
THROUGHOUT THE TIME THAT THEY
WERE PLAYING, IT'S OKAY FOR US
AS AMERICANS
TO BE CONCERNED, RIGHT?
BECAUSE THEY WASN'T PLAYING
THE BEST
BASKETBALL.
AND WE WERE USED TO, WE
WERE ACCUSTOMED TO SEEING
A CERTAIN TYPE OF
MEN'S TEAM, USA,
MEN'S BASKETBALL TEAM.
AND THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE
CONCERN
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE WERE
DOUBTING THEM
ARE NOT ONE OF THEM TO WIN FOR
OUR COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, YOU LET THEM ENJOY
THE MOMENT, YOU LET THEM DO
WHAT THEY DO. IT'S ALL FUN.
IT'S ALL GOOD
AND BE A CHAMPION, KENDRICK
PERKINS JOINS THE SHOW
ESPN, WHO STREAMS?
CO-HOST ALONGSIDE CASSIDY? HER
BIRTH CURRENTLY CALLING US
FROM INSIDE,
DRAYMOND GREENS HEAD WHERE
HE'S HAVING BREAKFAST IN BED.
TJ SAID, THE BEST
EGGS HE EVER HAD. WERE AT 4:00
IN THE MORNING, A PUFF DADDY'S
HOUSE IN MIAMI, WHERE THE BEST
SCRAMBLED EGGS YOU EVER HAD
HENDRICKS.
MAY, I JUST MAKE SURE
YOU HAD A LOOK.
AT EASE ON A PERKY KNOW, THERE
WAS CHEESE ON THEM EGGS.
YOU GOT TO BE
KENDRICK AS SOMEONE
WHO IS NOW CALLING, YOU KNOW,
THESE GAMES ARE ANALYZING
THESE GAMES OR LOOKING AT THE
LEAGUE DIFFERENTLY. HAS IT
CHANGED YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
BASKETBALL? HAVE YOU NOTICED
THAT YOU LOOK AT BASKETBALL
DIFFERENT FROM BEING A PLAYER
TO NOW BEING AN ANNOUNCER?
WELL, NO, NOT REALLY BECAUSE
YOU KNOW, ANY GUY THAT
ANY GUY THAT
THAT, THAT KNOWS ME
OR THERE WAS A
TEAMMATE OF MINE.
THEY KNOW THAT I WAS ALWAYS A
FAN OF BASKETBALL,
AND THEY
I ALWAYS USED TO SAY MAN, WHY
NOT SOMETHING ELSE ON TV? I
WOULD LITERALLY GO HOME AND
WATCH
ALL DIFFERENT GUY. I WOULD
HAVE
FOUR TVS ON WATCHING
FOR DIFFERENT GAMES
ON LEAGUE PASS. SO
I ALWAYS
VALUE GAMES, ALWAYS VALUE
OTHER PLAYERS THAT
WASN'T SUPER STARS
AND SO NOW
BEING AWAY FROM THE GAME AND
THEN MY NEW CAREER,
THE ONLY THING I LOOK AT
DIFFERENTLY NOW IS THAT I
LOOK AT THE SUPERSTARS
DIFFERENTLY
AND I WATCH
WHY ARE THEY ABLE TO CARRY
THEIR TEAM AND
THINGS TO THAT NATURE? THAT'S
THE ONLY THING THAT IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE
WHILE I WAS ON THE WHILE I WAS
PLAYING BASKETBALL,
ALWAYS KNEW WHAT SUPERSTARS
COULD DO IT
WAS CAPABLE OF DOING FOR US
HAVING HUGE NIGHT.
BUT NOW
I WATCH THE OTHERS, THE
OTHERS THAT DON'T GET THE
RECOGNITION OF GUYS LIKE
PJ TUCKER,
WHO
CAN HAVE ZERO POINT IN THE
GAME,
SIX OF A FINALS AND WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP
PLAYING
CHAMPIONSHIP PLAYING 33
MINUTES.
IT'S AND
SO THE INTO THE OUTSIDE WORLD,
IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS A
NON-FACTOR BUT GOD LIKE
MYSELF,
I SAW
THE PLACE THAT HE WAS MAKING
I
SAW IT AT THE EXTRA
POSSESSIONS THAT HE WAS
GETTING THE CHARGES THAT HE
WAS TAKING
DOING MAKING THE WIND PLAYS
THAT DIDN'T SHOW UP IN THE
STAT SHEET.
KENDRICK PERKINS JOINS THE
SHOW
ESPN
CO-HOST OF HOOP STREAMS AND
NOMS OF COURSE ON TWITTER.
HE'S ALWAYS TELLING YOU TO
CARRY ON
SHARING HIS TWO SONS.
PERK. YOU KNOW, WHEN I, WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THIS TIME IN THE
BASKETBALL SEASON,
THERE'S A LITTLE WINDOW RIGHT
HERE.
WE JUST GOT BLESSED WITH THE
OLYMPICS. SUMMER LEAGUES,
KICKING BACK UP. THERE'S A
LITTLE TIME HERE
WHERE, YOU KNOW, BESIDES THE
DROOLY YOUR HOOPS, IN THE SUN
OR DYCKMAN AND
STUFF. YOU GOTTA REALLY
SEARCH FOR BASKETBALL.
WHAT'S IN YOUR NETFLIX QUEUE?
WHAT ARE YOU WATCHING BESIDES
HOOPS? I FEEL LIKE YOU GO DEEP
DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE ON A
PARTICULAR SERIES OR YOU BIG
BINGE-WATCH YOUR PERK
OR WELL. I'M NOT YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW, TO BE HONEST, LOOK.
LET ME, LET ME TELL YOU THIS,
I'M A, I'M A, I'M A BIG,
I'M A HUGE FAN
OF ANIMALS, RIGHT?
AND SO
SOME OF MY FAVORITE SHOWS
MAY BLOW YOUR MIND AWAY, LIKE,
I'M A,
I WATCH A SHOW CALLED
SWAMP PEOPLE.
THEY GO OUT AND KILL
ALLIGATORS FOR
IN LOUISIANA, RIGHT?
AND I WATCH A SHOW CALLED
WICKED TUNA.
I WATCH I WATCH MONSTER FISH,
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I
LOVE WATCHING. I'M BIG ON
THE DISCOVERY CHANNEL, I'M BIG
ON LIKE WATCHING STUFF
ABOUT ANIMALS AND THINGS THAT
OTHER COUNTRIES. LIKE I'M NOT
BEING
OLD, YOU KNOW, I DON'T DO
I DON'T DO OTHER THINGS
LIKE I DO, I'M NOT BIG ON
REALITY TV.
YOU KNOW, G ON,
THESE NEW
THESE NO LITTLE SERIES
THAT'S OUT.
I'M MORE OF A
BORING. SO I GOT LIKE I LIKE
REAL LIFE THINGS.
I'VE SO MANY QUESTIONS NOW,
CAN JUST WHAT I'VE BEEN
LOOKING FOR HER.
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT DIALED
INTO THE BACHELORETTE FINALE
TONIGHT. THAT'S NOT
ABSOLUTELY NICE. THAT'S
ANIMALS IN THE WILD, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING? THAT'S ANIMALS. IN
THE WILD ANIMALS. MATING IN
THE WILD.
ABSOLUTELY, I'M WATCHING. I'M
WATCHING LIKE, YOU KNOW, LIKE
ON SWAMPY BY WATCHING THIS
WOMAN
AND HER 17 YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
RIDE THROUGH THE EVERGLADES
OF
RIDE THROUGH THE EVERGLADES OF
EVERGLADES OF,
YOU KNOW,
LOUISIANA
BY THEMSELVES. WHY THEY
PUTTING UP
LIONS TO HUNT ALLIGATORS, TO,
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILY
AND MAKE INCOME. THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT I WAS
KENDRICK. PERKINS JOINS THE
SHOW BEEN LINES IN FOR RICH ON
THE RICH EISEN SHOW KENDRICK.
WHAT'S AND WHAT'S ONE ANIMAL
THAT PEOPLE MIGHT THINK IS
CUTE AND CUDDLY, BUT IS A
IS FAR MORE VICIOUS AND
FEROCIOUS.
YOU SAID
ONE TIME SO I COULDN'T HEAR
YOU. IT IS
THERE AN ANIMAL OUT THERE THAT
PEOPLE THINK IS CUTE AND
CUDDLY HAS A REPUTATION FOR
BEING SWEET BUT ACTUALLY
IS A KILLER AND HIS FEROCIOUS
AND WE SHOULD BE AWARE OF
WELL, I MEAN, YOU KNOW I ONLY
WATCH THE ANIMALS
AT SCLEROSIS.
I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ANIMALS OUT THAT IS
LIKE THAT. I WOULD CONSIDER
CUTE AND CUDDLY
BUT I ONLY
WATCH THE FEROCIOUS WAS, I'M
WATCHING GRAY WHITE TIGER
SHARK. YOU KNOW, THINGS
THAT'S IN THE WATER,
I'M WATCHING THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS I'M WATCHING, YOU KNOW,
LIKE I SAID ALLIGATOR
AND I WATCH THE GUYS
ROUTE FROM SNAKE. THAT'S MY
TYPE OF THING. I NEED
SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE ME STAY UP AT
NIGHT,
SO I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
INTERVIEWING DWIGHT
CINDY HAS ABOUT 12 OR 13,
EXOTIC SNAKES WHO YOU THINK
WOULD BE A GOOD SNAKE WRESTLER
IN THE NBA?
WHAT HAPPENED TO
WHITE HOUSE BECAUSE I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, HIM
MORE
ROB WILL CUT
CUT ENGINE BECAUSE THOSE ARE
THE TWO GUYS THAT ACTUALLY
THOSE ARE THE TWO GUYS THAT
ACTUALLY
OWN SNAKES.
SO I WOULD HAVE TO GIVE IT TO
THEM.
ROBERT COVINGTON
SNEAK OWNER, DIDN'T KNOW THAT
ABOUT COVINGTON, THANKS FOR
MAKING
US SMARTER TODAY PERK I
APPRECIATED YOU MENTIONED YOUR
LOVE OF ANIMALS IN THE WATER.
DO YOU GO IN THE WATER? ARE
YOU AFRAID TO SWIM IN THE
OCEAN? BECAUSE OF YOUR
KNOWLEDGE NOW
OF SHARKS.
ABSOLUTELY NOT NOT A FACT,
ONE THING THAT I HAVE ON MY
BUCKET LIST IS TO GO.
AND
AND GETTING A CAGE AND GO
ACTUALLY I
OFF THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA,
RIGHT IN THE PACIFIC OCEAN AND
GO OUT THERE AND LOOK AT THOSE
GREAT WHITES. SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS I HAVE ON MY
BUCKET LIST IS TO GET IN THE
CAGE
AND ACTUALLY GET DROPPED IN
THE WATER. I HOPE THAT THE
LINE NO PALPABLE CUZ I AM.
POP BECAUSE I AM ABOUT 75
POUNDS OVERWEIGHT SINCE I
START SINCE I STOPPED
PLAYING.
SO HOPEFULLY I CAN GET THAT
DONE BUT THAT'S ON MY BUCKET
LIST RIGHT THERE. BUT LOOK,
I'M TELLING YOU
IF I WASN'T A PROFESSIONAL
BASKETBALL PLAYER, I'LL BE A
PROFESSIONAL SWIMMER. YOU
CAN'T KEEP ME OUT THE WATER.
THE OCEAN,
THE SWIMMING POOLS. CREAKS,
WHATEVER IT. MAYBE PUT ME IN
THE WATER AND I'M A
FLOURISH WITH
KENDRICK PERKINS JOINING THE
SHOW. I'VE SO MANY MORE
QUESTIONS. HOW MUCH TIME DO WE
HAVE ON THIS SHOW NOW
BROCKMAN. I DON'T KNOW
AN ACTUAL BASKETBALL QUESTION
THOUGH, PERK LIKE, WHAT ARE
THE CELTICS DOING? LIKE,
I'M NOT LIKE THAT.
PROBABLY HALF THE WAY WATER
SHARKS,
REAL QUESTION. WHAT ARE THE
CELTICS DOING?
DOING? YO, LISTEN, I HAVE
THE SAME
OUT OF QUESTIONS MYSELF AND
LOOK, YOU KNOW, I
LIKE THE ADDITION OF
AL HORFORD,
I REALLY THOUGHT
THAT THE CELTICS SHOULD HAVE
PURSUED
SPENCER DINWIDDIE, IN MY
OPINION, I THOUGHT HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN A PERFECT MATCH
TO GO ALONGSIDE JASON
TATUM AND JAYLA BROWN BUT THEY
DIDN'T GET IT DONE.
I'M HEARING RUMORS,
THE DENNIS SCHRODER. I DON'T
KNOW HOW WELL
IT FITS, BUT I DO KNOW ONE
THING. PEYTON PREACHER SHOULD
NOT BE PLAYING SOME EARLY,
OKAY, HE'S PASSED IN. THIS
GUY IS A
NO PLAYER,
UNLESS HE WANTED TO PLAY,
BUT I WILL SAY THIS,
YOU KNOW, THE CELTICS
DON'T HAVE THAT MANY OPTIONS
TO CHOOSE
FROM
AND
BY THE WAY,
THE EASTERN CONFERENCE IS
GETTING BETTER,
YOU LOOK AT THE MIAMI HEAT.
THEY GOT BETTER THE ATLANTA
HAWKS GOT BETTER.
THE
BROOKLYN NETS ARE OBVIOUSLY
THE OTHER CHAMPIONS IN THE
MILWAUKEE BUCKS. OBVIOUSLY,
YOU, YOU KNOW THINGS ARE
GETTING BETTER.
THE KNICKS GOT BETTER.
LIKE, I'M JUST WAITING ON THE
CELTICS TO ACTUALLY
GET
BETTER.
WE GOT THE WHEELS.
WOMEN'S BASKETBALL.
IT'S ADVENTURING WITH KENDRICK
PERKINS
KENDRICK. MY DAD RAN WITH THE
BULLS IN PAMPLONA IS THAT ON
YOUR BUCKET LIST.
AS A COUNTRY BOY. GROWING UP
IN BEAUMONT, TEXAS.
I ACTUALLY KNOW HOW DANGEROUS
BULLS ARE
AND I KNOW ONE THING FROM A
GUY THAT WENT
COW-TIPPING A COUPLE TIMES AS
A
A YOUNGSTER.
WHO WAS
THEN CALLED OR SOMETHING THAT
YOU WANT TO STAY FAR AWAY FROM
ME AS POSSIBLE.
I APPRECIATE THE ADVICE THERE
KENDRICK. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING THE SHOW AND IF
YOU EVER WANT TO TALK
ADVENTURING OR OUT IN THE WILD
OR ANY OF THIS STUFF, PLEASE,
PLEASE CALL BACK. WE WILL
ALWAYS ACCEPT THE CALL.
CALL, I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
PLACE FOREVER.
WHERE EVER, YOU EVER GET THE
CHANCE TO HAVE SCRAMBLED EGGS
AT DADDY'S HOUSE. I'M TELLING
YOU
DON'T FORGET THE CHEESE.
MIGHT HAVE SOME
GRIT STUPOR.
YOU KNOW, WE DO. SO
LET'S GET IT. I FEEL LIKE A
DISCOVERY SHOW JUST LIKE
TRAVELING THE GLOBE.
WE COME ON
THE WATER. GREAT SHOES ON THIS
SHOW, VERY INTO THAT
BORIS DIAW
HAS TURNED INTO QUITE THE
ADVENTURE. YOU CAN LOOK UP A
VIDEO OF BORIS SAILING ACROSS
THE TRANNY MAKING THE
TRANSATLANTIC SALE
LOOKING AT ALL THE WHALES ON
HIS YOUTUBE, BORIS DIAW
HAS BECOME AN ADVENTURE.
IMAGINE BORIS AND PERK. YOU
GOT THIS FRENCH GUY.
BELONGS ESPRESSO.
AND WILDLIFE PHOTOGRAPHY.
THE A BIG PERK FROM BEAUMONT
TEXAS,
WHO'S EATEN
BED-AND-BREAKFAST, AND INSIDE
YOUR HEAD. I'M WATCHING THAT
SHOW. I'M THE MY WATCHING
WATCHING EVERY APP. THAT'S A
GREAT JOB. WOULDN'T HAVE
PEGGED. BIG PERK IS LIKE A
WATER GUY.
JUST HE SAYS HE LOVES IT.
OLYMPIC SWIMMING. CAN'T KEEP
HIM OUT OF A CREEK.
AND HE SAID CREEKS, LAKES
PONDS,
JUST A BODY OF WATER PERKS UP
SO MUCH HAPPENING,
MY KIND OF INTERVIEW, MAN.
WHAT ARE THE CELTICS GOING TO
DO IN FREE AGENCY?
FREE AGENCY?
FREE DIVING WITH SHARKS.
A JAGUAR.
COULD HE BE THE NEW VOICE OF
THOSE
EARTH SHOWS
INSTEAD OF DAVID ATTENBOROUGH?
SO GOOD? YES,
PLANET EARTH NEVER USED BY
KENDRICK PERKINS LIKE DAVID
ATTLEBORO FINE, YOU'RE OUT